[Applaudissements]
à fond pour toi ah c'est gentil merci et
pour moi tu resteras une star je te le
dis tu vas voir
je te le dis voilà je te sens très en
forme en tout cas ouais vraiment ouais
mais tu avais fait sûrement d'être
éliminé donc je suis désolé d'avoir
joué le jeu au contraire
tu es obligé attendez on comprend tout à
fait tu es dans un jeu tu suis les
règles du jeu et tu as très bien fait de
jouer le jeu et c'est c'est top tu aimes
bien joué bon là tu reviens là elle est
vraiment c'est fini voilà je voulais
vous dire c'est fini voilà elle est pas
revenue c'est sûr
Frédéric c'est aussi le tarbac du jour
il avait promis à Nicolas de le choisir
s'il remportait l'épreuve des poteaux
sauf que tu ne sais pas passer comme
prévu et c'est pour ça que je vous dis
Frédéric je ne le porte pas dans mon
cœur voilà je ne je je vois la chaîne
beaucoup Nicolas j'ai Tania c'était ma
préférée je l'ai dit et je le redis ici
voilà donc je préférais inviter Tania
voilà mais c'est vrai que voilà j'aime
bien les gens qui que là qui tiennent
leurs promesses et dans Koh-Lanta c'est
vrai que c'est pas c'est aussi de la
stratégie mais bon Frédéric voilà il
avait dit qu'il choisirait Nicolas et
pas du tout regardé si je gagne les
photos je partirai sur Nicolas parce que
j'ai envie de partager ça avec lui on
est c'est assez symbolique parce qu'on
est allié depuis vraiment le le deuxième
jour ce serait une belle histoire ça
finirait bien on a commencé ensemble on
finit ensemble j'espère que tu
comprendras mon
mon raisonnement Nico mais je vais
choisir Tania pour pour aller en finale
[Musique]
tu peux le défoncer vas-y c'est un
traître de boutons
Tania vous avez été héroïque de ça parce
qu'avec Julie vous avez tenté de les
contrecarrer depuis le départ il nous
gonfle ils sont sexistes je comprends
pas il a gagné 7 à 2 contre vous en
finale pourquoi les gens ont voté pour
Frédéric j'ai pas compris c'est vous qui
méritiez j'ai pas compris Tania je te
dis la vérité pourquoi tu as mis un
pourquoi pourquoi Tania why aux
personnes qui ont voté après moi
objectivement je savais que j'allais pas
gagner mais honnêtement je comprends pas
parce que elles ont tout été trahis par
Frédéric tout le monde lui donne sa voix
mais après c'est le jeu il a toujours le
mec il a trahi tout le monde tout le
monde ça a été le Tarba de l'aventure et
il gagne à la fin il vote pour lui non
mais c'est incroyable y compris son pote
Nicolas qui va voter pour lui à la fin
mais c'est incroyable alors que Tania tu
es la meilleure
si j'étais la meilleure j'aurais gagné
pas du tout je veux dire il y a souvent
des meilleurs qui ne gagnent pas et je
dis pas ça pour dire donc la finale
s'est déroulée entre toi Tania et et
force est constater que ça n'a pas
vraiment été voilà c'est tu avais
travaillé les poteaux avant non pas du
tout pas du tout c'est on travaille pas
les poteaux avant non les trains enfin
moi personnellement je les ai pas
travaillés déjà j'étais blessé donc
d'arriver
un truc donc tu peux jouer au tennis ou
pas la semaine dernière donc pour le
match c'est quand est-ce qu'on m'a dit
on m'a dit que tu es prêt la semaine
dernière
il faut faire un défi là parce que la
dernière fois
que je te propose un truc
qu'est-ce que tu fais le qu'est-ce que
tu fais le 21 ou le 22 juin
c'est la semaine prochaine ah le 22
pourquoi mes 21 c'est bon
est-ce que tu non mais est-ce que tu
veux jouer avec moi sur le central de
Roland-Garros entre Yannick Noah
et ouais parce que j'ai ouais on va
jouer on joue sur le on sera en double
tous les deux contre Yannick Noah et un
partenaire ok mais on gagne non mais
attends tu crois que je vais venir pour
faire alors par contre il faut qu'on
rejoue peut-être avant semaine prochaine
une fois parce que ça fait 4 ans que
j'ai pas joué au tennis vous ajuster
tous les deux en tant que Dieu
allez alors le prof commence sur le
filet
alors tu as de la chance parce que peu
de temps après tu as fait ton grand
retour dans l'émission même si tu avais
été éliminé donc je voudrais qu'on
revoit j'en élimination ta première
élimination parce que tu as un triste
record ton prénom est inscrit sur 36
bulletins dépouillés par Denis Brogniart
en 15 émissions on n'a jamais autant
écrit le nom Tania c'est fou ça regardez
Tania Tania Tania c'est-à-dire Tania
Tania les aventuriers de la tribu rouge
ont décidé de vous éliminer et leur
sentence est tirer vos casques
honnêtement je mets attendais pas du
tout
[Applaudissements]
honnêtement et ça a été un grand
stratège tout au long de l'aventure et
même au final il gagne Koh-Lanta on a en
ayant trahi des personnes donc
honnêtement faut être un bon stratège
donc il a gagné Koh-Lanta donc forcément
il m'a dit
les poteaux donc déjà à partir de là moi
je trouve que quand tu gagnes les
poteaux tu mérites de gagner Koh-Lanta
c'est sûr qu'il sera
ah mais je te le dis c'est sûr
bien je connais Tania et incroyable donc
je te dis je suis sûr je vois pas
pourquoi tu serais pas non mais tu vas
t'entraîner au poto en fait il faut même
quand tu manges tu es comme ça et tu
manges un truc moi si je perds Koh-Lanta
je vais m'entraîner au poteau c'est les
profs que vous redoutez de toute j'ai
déjà parce qu'en fait pourquoi tu
t'entraînes pas au poteau parce que tu
dis je serai jamais au poteau et ça en
fait l'histoire et tu dis on verra
enregistrer il y a aussi le truc là
quand il faut s'accrocher là comme ça
sur le camp mais
qui fait l'aventure j'ai adoré c'est
l'aventure d'une vie Koh-Lanta c'est
incroyable
franchement l'autre je l'appelle l'autre
parce que Frédéric je le déteste
vous êtes une perdante magnifique
d'ailleurs vous êtes surnommé le Phoenix
l'autre il a trahi de bout en bout c'est
pas beau ce qu'il a fait vous dites
c'est le jeu non bah il a été dit il a
été bon non mais là trahirt ses amis
honnêtement c'est trop ce gars là
Frédéric franchement moi je le déteste
et vous vous détestez aussi
on a créé vraiment et pas comme une ouf
non et surtout j'arrive à me détacher un
peu du jeu parce que sinon je serais
trop négative je pense parce qu'avec
toutes les voix que j'ai eu si je devais
penser ça de tout le monde bah
j'aimerais personne à part deux
personnes vous arrivez à pas Laurent
vouloir complètement je me concentre sur
les personnes que j'aime bien et puis je
regarde le positif parce que c'est un
jeu avant tout donc voilà
on va revoir
[Rires]
on va passer au meilleures images de la
saison tu vas les commentaires avec nous
images la plus ouf sans aucune
hésitation c'est celle d'Esteban Esteban
qui nous a fait une
[Rires]
je vous laisse découvrir qui sera votre
adversaire pour ce duel demain
je comprends à vos regards et à vos
réactions la surprise de constater de
kestban a gagné face à Clémence bonjour
Esteban bonjour Alors je vois en plus
que vous êtes surpris de le voir comme
ça et Stéphane souffre d'une allergie
mais aucune contre-indication pour
poursuivre l'aventure
[Musique]
je l'adore vraiment
invité
j'adore ce mec et puis il a un truc
voilà ça aussi tu vois c'est un mec qui
a envie de le revoir j'adore belle
personnalité vraiment c'est une femme
que j'adore vraiment tu vois là tu vois
je suis là à la politique tu vois je me
sens je sens que je vais être monstreux
mais c'est ça qui manquait dans combien
de temps c'est des stars en fait on
n'avait pas vu le Star depuis longtemps
et là il y a des personnages
emblématiques comme Esteban comme Tania
et qu'on s'est et c'est vrai que ça m'a
beaucoup vous allez voir les meilleurs
images de la saison des commentaires la
saison était très fort c'est vrai
c'était une belle saison ouais c'est
gentil il y a eu pas mal de
rebondissements donc finalement
et moi je sentais pas du tout que ça
allait être Frédéric qui allait gagner
mine de rien c'est aussi c'est aussi une
surprise quand même
enfin moi franchement depuis le début il
y a eu que des rebondissements des
fausses pistes et tout ça effectivement
vous revoir Tania alors qu'il y a deux
mois et demi vous étiez là un peu comme
ça misérable je trouve que c'est juste
incroyable non mais en plus tu es 100
fois plus enfant que moi tu as changé un
truc capillairement aussi ah non pas du
tout
[Musique]
vous êtes déjà allé le Chili j'ai tout
fait
juste Esteban c'est je vous dis je suis
fan j'embrasse d'ailleurs j'aimerais
bien le rencontrer un jour Esteban
et c'est une darka parce que sur
l'épreuve des insectes il a fait perdre
toute son équipe c'était un très grand
moment ça aussi
c'est chaud pour manger au cas où je
vais te manger toi là-bas en plus en
dessert
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est bon
même pas besoin de croquer allez c'est
balle de merde
malheureusement Tania Frédéric Esteban
et Clémence c'est terminé j'en ai marre
Denis j'en ai marre de passer à côté de
chaque confort
[Musique]
plein de SMS de chariyad parce que je
vous ai proposé de jouer au tennis avec
vous avec Yannick Noah et donc il y a
des gens qui regardent l'équipe donc
Kakou météo qui disent il y a une
meuf qui est lui il t'aime bien la rando
il va privatiser le Mont Blanc ce matin
communauté incroyable ça va être
incroyable donc c'est bien comme ça pour
venir te voir et de 6 ça joue quand même
j'ai Adrien maigrir un des meilleurs
joueurs de paddle qui m'écrit parce
qu'il est jaloux que j'ai pas choisi je
pense que Adrien mais je t'aurais choisi
pour ce double qui m'a mis qui me met
frérot deux six femmes c'est un gagnable
je dis pas du tout je peux dire que
Tania je Tania et Tania elle a une maman
Daniel perd pas
elle a un mentale
Adrien tu verras nous voir Adrien
d'ailleurs euh Tania donc merci d'être
là finaliste de Koh-Lanta c'est c'est
déjà une victoire pour toi d'avoir été
finaliste honnêtement vu mon parcours 2e
et
la plus belle victoire chaque fois à
côté de c'est fou même là je l'aurais
jamais dû être choisi par Frédéric moi
je savais que les garçons se
choisissaient donc quand il me dit Tania
mais là moi je tombe quoi
il va gagner il sait il s'est il était
trop beau mais je te jure il a trahi le
mec et je me suis dit à la fin
l'histoire va être belle et en fait
c'est Tania qui va qui va gagner ouais
mais c'est dommage c'est pas grave mais
même quand il m'a choisi je pouvais même
pas être trop joyeuse parce que ça me
faisait de la peine pour Nicolas mais au
final je suis trop contente
ça fait combien de temps que tu es
revenu de Koh-Lanta en fait depuis
septembre fin septembre
alors il y avait Martin aussi dans
Koh-Lanta c'est Martin c'est voilà c'est
c'est le relou mais qu'on aime bien dans
l'aventure à chaque fois qu'il était à
l'écran il faisait que de se plaindre
mais bon c'était en bas regardez
[Musique]
je suis désolé je suis pas du tout de
bonne humeur meurt de faim rien à
bouffer sur ce camp tu as envie d'aller
me casser le cul à sortir c'est le
poisson j'ai le moral dans les
chaussettes tout me saoules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec des personnes de la production donc
la nuit la nuit
mais bon pendant la nuit tu vois rien on
peut rien faire quoi donc enfin je vois
pas comment tu peux tricher la nuit
Joubert là elle a repris ça en mange je
peux te dire qu'Alexia ça rigole pas là
ça ça filou comme on dit il y a Élodie
aussi souvenez vous qui a marqué cette
saison elle est partie tôt dans
l'aventure parce qu'elle commençait un
petit peu voilà elle était elle était
présente quoi regardez
Elodie j'ai 35 ans et je suis
responsable marketing et communication
dans le jeu de société je suis
pétillante déterminée haute perché
le chant représente pour moi une
thérapie au quotidien et je suis la plus
heureuse du monde
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui voudraient bien
dormir merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ton meilleur souvenir mon
meilleur souvenir ça a été à la course
d'orientation quand je trouve le
poignard au bout de 4 40 était tellement
épuisé au 39e jour là quand je le trouve
je pense
chez toi tu as perdu un truc tu dis bon
laisse tomber c'est pas grave non mais
c'est vrai je rachète mais là c'est
c'était pas possible non faire 4h40 mais
39e jour où tu manges pas tu dors par
terre enfin j'étais vraiment épuisé là
honnêtement c'est quoi le premier truc
que tu as fait quand tu es revenu ah
serré mes proches dans mes bras c'est
vraiment ce qui m'a le plus manqué sur
ma famille adore non même pas non j'ai
pas du tout été frustré par rapport à la
nourriture oh je le vivais assez bien
tranquille
je savais que si je buvais énormément
d'eau je pouvais combler ma faim donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas été frustré
par la nourriture coucou à Manu vivesque
un pote à toi qui a un très grand joueur
de paddle il est monstrueux voilà Manu
j'espère ne pas te rencontrer en tournoi
pendant très longtemps la dernière fois
que j'ai rencontré j'ai pris un et un
donc bravo non non c'est un pote c'est
un très très grand joueur des plus
grands espoirs français et il est il est
mon
il est reparti exactement c'est quoi ton
pire souvenir j'en ai pas même quand
j'étais éliminé évincé au final j'ai
toujours trouvé quelque chose de positif
quand
je sais face à Esteban je reviens je
trouve le collier d'immunité donc au
final il y a rien de pas bien dans mon
aventure
moi je te jure la vérité au bout de 6
heures dans Koh-Lanta il est ramenez-moi
j'en peux plus non
là-bas bah honnêtement juste des proches
comme ça une fois par semaine tu les
serres dans tes bras merci
le courrier ou
la peine j'aurais pu rester au final je
suis une personne simple donc je pouvais
me contenter de très peu
l'hygiène c'est comment là-bas
c'est moi on a de l'eau on fait Kippour
le ramadan déjà on est pas bien tu vois
maintenant je sais mais au final je
pense qu'on s'habitue l'humain s'habitue
à tout à ne pas manger à être sale non
vraiment pas je pense que tout le monde
sentait mauvais machin salut en fait
parce que il y a une technique apparable
est-ce que vous faites vous vous lécher
comme ça ah oui le poignet vous laissez
sécher et vous voyez et si vous voyez
que votre poignet est pas bon les gars
attention va d'aimer comme floraison je
me serais choper une infection
et là et là-bas il y a aucun aucun bail
de mec rien on y pense même pas déjà
quand on mange pas 0 quoi vraiment même
le premier jour on se dit pas ouais
peut-être le premier jour on peut se
dire ah lui il est pas mal déjà
très vite mais après tu es là pour le
jeu tu as envie de gagner le jeu tu es
pas là
aujourd'hui j'ai eu la semaine dernière
qui arrive qui est frais propre oui les
frais mon frère il sort de la douche il
a mangé il a mangé nos job le merguez
avant il est frais mon frère alors bon
on se voit les épreuves il y a que Denis
en fait que tu as envie de pécho dans
Koh-Lanta Sophie cost c'est pas elle qui
sera le contraire
écoute pour l'instant
on se verra plus tard qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette histoire vous en avez
parlé avec vous vous avez refait le
match là non mais c'était hyper
longtemps on s'est pécho voilà
on est pas sorti ensemble sortir ça va
une relation
de niveau
gosse
j'ai vu la semaine dernière bon délire
Denis non non il est pas mal super
gentil
très très sympa
juste je l'ai battu tennis Saint-Denis
tu pourras lui demander on s'est
rencontré un tournoi ah bah il aime bien
le tennis donc il est très
sportifs alors j'adore Denis et la
première chose d'ailleurs qui m'a vu
quand il m'a vu il m'a dit quand est-ce
qu'on joue au tennis Denis j'ai gagné ça
y est maintenant passe à autre chose
je demandais lui je dis pas voilà et
vous rappelez
une épreuve de force aussi ici
vos partenaires là vous allez être
courtois quand même avec Tania en double
et on joue quand tu veux mon Denis je
pense que maintenant il met une tôle
hein au tennis je pense qu'il me met une
vraie Toulon je pense que Tania
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu as envie
qu'est-ce que tu fais là maintenant
alors c'est quoi ton bah je continue ma
vie moi je suis diététicienne
nutritionniste et coach voilà j'ai j'ai
mes clients mes patients tranquille quoi
de demande en mariage quand on devient
connu ça arrive hein
non pas vraiment
ça
vraiment est-ce qu'il y a des mecs qui
vont plus facilement vers toi maintenant
des mecs des femmes tout le monde parce
que comme on me reconnaît forcément les
gens viennent vers moi plus facilement
qu'une femme
tu es très jolie tu es sympathique voilà
tu as beaucoup de qualité mais ça a pas
changé quoi tu as pas une conne ou pas
sur côté non non je suis très bien
tranquille
non mais c'est naturel
Douglas est-ce que vous voudriez faire
de la télé
quel genre de thé quel genre de télé
voudriez-vous faire alors repose mieux
ma question bah voilà faire des plateaux
comme ça moi j'aime bien mais après
télé-réalité c'est pas du tout ma
personnalité
faire la comédienne
moi je trouve qu'il faut il faut
franchement il faut faire un jeu
d'aventure autour de toi vraiment il
faut que tu sois je te jure que c'est
vrai moi j'aurais fait une espèce un
espèce de truc genre dans tu vois comme
ça tu montes on t'envoie dans un dans un
endroit et que c'est qui peut battre
Tania
moi j'aurais fait un truc comme ça tu
vois il y a des gens qui viennent te
défier sur des épreuves etc il y a une
cagnotte tu vois pour une association si
tu gagnes pour une association si c'est
pour de l'argent je vois un truc comme
ça il y a peut-être quelque chose à
faire tu vas en parler bravo on va en
parler à vous même non
allez merci Tania merci merci d'avoir
été atteignant et le 21 on est ensemble
voilà et on va on chez nous
sérieux
sur le centrale de Roland Yannick c'est
en fait c'est l'anniversaire de sa
victoire et en fait je vous dis c'est
j'ai fait un don pour une association et
c'était et donc voilà et donc c'était ça
et chercher quelqu'un pour jouer avec
moi avec une femme
tu vas tu vas jouer 90% des balles merci
en tout cas Tania d'avoir été avec nous